the first thing you gotta set up is well
what how am I going to use key results
okay someone say let's t evil okay now
it usually is ten teen or two usually
okay first reason is not can't in your
choice with their reviews okay so that's
no use to you secondly I'm not going to
make it ten differences I'm actually
just going to say okay here is why
hey if I've got ten feet up on two then
I'm going to be dealing in 10 feet up
close we mark sine theta right this is
the way we normally use T results okay
but if I just double all the angles 10x
okay 2x columns 2x sine 2x it's the same
terrible it's just wearing different
clothes okay in fact the difference
between solving a question like 4 minus
x squared equals 0 and 4 minus T squared
equals 0 since a question you're going
to do it exactly the same way but just
the latest yes sir you could technically
have infinite I guess
so if T equals tennis there's one I can
say 10 2 X will be equal to and now I'm
just going to quit the familia t results
they are not prepared into T on one
month in the square right I could say
sine 2x but I'm not going to anyone
doing Ramon yet the light is a sign
right maybe I'll need sign later but
there's nothing to talk about is
Mountain over there
I will be convert easy way so I'm going
to write cos 2 X I'm going to write the
where remember which is 1 minus T
squared T squared but there immediately
I'm going to convert that into second
we're going to be equal positive attacks
especially the normal people
you are the angles are the most positive
yes they're there the other affected
people run back to the answer duty of
the government right work the book why
would you like can't 500 nu derivative
you take if keyword can 250x then 10500
equity is blah blah blah blah and if you
can protect how doctors that work
because I can't attend to any clue
they can't hand I wonder next including
because you change the substitution key
so you change the bear right so they
don't come out of it I mean it's just an
abbreviation called original
double-angle ten results that we do 10 2
X is 2 10 X on 1 minus 2x which is that
just much so I'll just give it a
possible able to read okay that looks
good
that is one more thing I know what KJ is
no effectuates is where this it cuz it's
fine but a simple way of saying I mean
that's one of the division is what I can
and I have 10 so therefore that tells me
that corrects is the reciprocal you had
with that yeah yeah yeah just just slip
it if you click this what do you get 1
over time which is caught if you do the
base you get one of the table that's all
say now we really do some substitution
okay so I'm going to go time tables I to
T of 1 minus T squared times 1 over T on
T big if I just got the strategies I
- robot so anything I can do go ahead
you could but I noted it I'm not getting
getting you volunteered on that because
I look at all the other T results that
every act right like that so on the
final time equals one plus what
by then what does you do to defend them
so this one if 1 minus T squared over 1
minus T squared
yes so it won't move into the square now
remember this is a show question so even
though you're like oh I see it
you still actually have to go oh yeah
okay on the farm that will be the 2 TSP
0 you would be so that inhalation time
as your wife how how did you know that
you should have brought it what the one
under the same tactic
you mean computer yeah because when I
did the left hand side
I got one backing how I simplified out
the left hand side and gotten something
else like there's square roots or or or
two fractions or something like that
then whatever is that I end up here as
simple as I can get is where I'm going
to go if I hadn't done T results if I
just gone up because you can't describe
to you if I start on the left hand side
I work I work and work I substitute and
manipulate but I've always got one I
always got one over here so I'm looking
for where I can plug this one from where
is it going to come from
I'm going to just temperature determines
alternatively I started on the right I'm
going to work work work work where you
keeping on the Left I know there's going
to be a jainism nobody caught how am I
going to get
[Music]